الساعات الاخيره بدات طلائع اغاثه تدخل
الى سوريا منها حمله دشنها الهلال الاحمر
القطري مكونه من 5 شاحنات محمله بخمس
وثلاثين طنا من المواد العاجله مولها
صندوق قطر للتنميه ونقلت عبر القوات
الجويه الاميريه القطريه
ينضم الينا من معبر الراعي على الحدود
السوريه التركيه سعود المعاضيد مدير اداره
الاعلام بجمعيه قطر الخيريه اهلا بك سيد
سعود سيد سعود هل لك ان تضعنا في طبيعه
وصوره الجهود التي تقدمونه
السلام عليكم مساء الخير طبعا نحدثكم من
معبر الراعي اللهم لك الحمد والشكر اولا
تم نقل النازحين خاصه المتضررين من اجراء
الزلزال سواء في تركيا او في سوريا طبعا
جهود قطر خيريه اللهم لك الحمد كانت اولى
الجمعيات او المؤسسات
المتحركه كائنات عاجله بعد ضرب الزلزال
بساعتين تقريبا وتم نقل
العوائل الايتام الاطفال الى الملاجئ الى
المخيمات وتم توزيع ابرز الاحتياجات
الاحتياجات
الضروريه التي لابد تكون متوفره وتم
توفيرها وسيتم توفير احتياجات اكثر منها
المستلزمات الطبيه مساعدات معيشيه اسعافات
اوليه
غذائيه ملابس وخيام لكل
المتضررين طبعا
تم نقل في الايام تقريبا
في تركيا وسوريا وتم اسعاف ما يمكن اسعافه
يعني سيد سعود انتم منذ ايام تتابعون عن
كثب
اثار الزلزال ما الذي شاهدتموه كيف تصفون
المشهد
نعم نحن كفريقة الخيريه كنا اثناء الزلزال
متواجدين في مدينه غازي عنتاب وشفنا طبعا
راينا المشهد المروع الكارثي وعشنا هذه
الاجواء مع جميع المتضررين
مشاهد كارثيه مشاهد مؤلمه مشاهد لا يمكن
اني اوصفها لكم او حتى لا يمكنكم ان
تتخيلون هذه المشاهد خاصه ونحن في مدينه
غازي عنتاب ونحن في
الدقيقه التي فيها الزلزال كنا نائمين
صحينا من النوم لم
نتخيل ان هذا او هذه الكارثه حقيقه كنا
نتخيل انها حلم وسنصحى من هذا الحلم ولكن
هي واقع وحقيقيه وتاثرنا جميعا وعشنا
معاناه جميع
المتضرره
جلسنا بضعه ايام ثلاثه ايام بعد الزلزال
دون اكل دون
تدفئه دون ماء
كنا ناكل او نشرب فقط الشوربه لمده ثلاث
ايام مره واحده في اليوم نحن والعوائل
ولكن اللهم لك الحمد
للدعم جاء من دوله قطر
واستطعنا ان نوفر الخيام في اسرع وقت ممكن
الان وانا احدثكم
نعمل على على خيام لايتام قطر الخيريه
للعوائل المتضرره للنساء اللهم لك الحمد
وفرنا تقريبا 300 خيمه امس طبعا ليله
البارحه سكن والخيام جاهزه بكل
المستلزمات سواء المستلزمات الطبيه المواد
الغذائيه مواد التدفئه
من الوجبات الوجبات جهود قطر خيريه توزع
ما بين 27 الف الى خمسه او خمسين الف وجبه
بين سوريا وتركيا يوميا هناك مخيمات سوف
يتم تشيلها خلال الايام القليله القادمه
سواء في
تركيا او حتى في سوريا في جنديرس عزاز
الباب او عفرين اللهم لك الحمد
الجهودة الدول التي سارعت لادخال
المساعدات الى تركيا ولكن ما تقييمكم لي
الاستجابه الدوليه للمساعده بعد ايام على
الزلزال وما هي ابرز الحاجات
مثل ما ذكرت لك الحاجات كبيره وابرز
الحاجات لابد توفير المستلزمات الطبيه
الاسعافات الاوليه المواد الغذائيه ملابس
التدفئه
المسكن لهذه العوايل العوايل ممكن بعد
الزلزال
كانت تنام في الشواء في الحدائق لا يوجد
لها ماوى لا توجد لها بيوت
خسرت كل شيء في ظرف دقيقه واحده اللهم لك
الحمد تحركات دوله قطر او جمعيه قطر خيريه
او صندوق قطر للتنميه الهلال الاحمر
تحركات عاجله اللهم لك الحمد والشكر
وباذن الله سوف نحاول توفير جميع
الاحتياجات بشكل عاجل ولكن اقول لكم وانا
من ارض الميدان الوضع صعب الوضع كارثي نحن
بحاجه ان نتعاون نحن بحاجه عن مع اخواننا
قدر المستطاع وبكل طاقه واجهت لتوفير هذه
المواد لتوفير هذه الخدمات هذه المساعدات
بشكل عاجل بشكل ضروري ونعم سوف نتعب هذه
الايام ولكن
الذي يرى هذا هذا الوضع سوف
لا لا استطيع ان ان اوصف الوضع حاليا ما
استطيع ان اقول بان الوضع
كان في ولكن من عبر شاشتكم واقول بان لا
احد ابدا لا تستخسر المساعده ممكن
القيمه البسيطه جدا فهي تنقذ حياه الانسان
تنقذ حياه انسان القيمه البسيطه التي
تستطيع المساعده بها تساعد
قس مع الناس يقف مع اخوانك فانك بهذه
المساعده هذا التحرك الذي انت تراه بسيط
فهو ينقذ حياه انسان
سيد صعود يعني
الجمعيه القطريه او جمعيه قطر الخيريه
اعلنت عن اكثر من حمله لجمع التبرعات ما
مدى الاستجابه لهذه الحملات وهل بالفعل
هنالك تضامن وتكافل شعبي ودعم لهذه
الحملات
نعم هناك تحرك شعبي في دوله قطر وجمعيه
قطر الخيريه بالتعاون مع الصندوق قطر
للتنميه طبعا هناك حمله حمله عون سند
لاقراسه اخواننا في سوريا وفي تركيا
والتحرك الشعبي بدا منذ ايام واليوم هو
اليوم الرئيسي لهذه الحمله هناك حجز شعبي
في دوله قطر هناك
تعاون هناك وقفه مع اخواننا في سوريا وفي
تركيا وقفه من الشعب القطري وكما ترون في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هذه الحمله حمله
عون السند بالتعاون مع المنظمات والمؤسسات
الانسانيه هو الخيريه في دوله قطر كلنا
نقف وقفه واحده كلنا يد واحده
لنستطيع اقافه اخواننا في سوريا وفي تركيا
شكرا لك صعود المعاضيد مدير اداره الاعلام
بجمعيه قطر الخيريه